So I want to use this opportunity to,
completely, define, an image gradient in a discrete form.
For a two dimensional function, F of x and y,
the partial derivative would basically be del of F x,
y with respect to x, and this is of course in just x direction.
And of course what we would basically be looking for is a small epsilon x
over x, between the two different values with epsilon gong to infinity.
For the discrete data, we can approximate this using finite differences.
Which basically says for x, the del F x, y could be approximated with just
moving 1 in, index point, in x, so of course, this would be as we have always
looked at images to be discrete samples of moving from one row to the others.
In this case, of course, one column to the other keeping y the same, and
of course approximating with the difference like this.
This is in essence what we just did in the previous cases of 1-D example,
when we just took one row and subtracted from the other one, of course we would
do the same, for this one, for rows, for y, and of course, columns for x.
And this is basically an approximation that allows us to do simple image
differences and use derivatives for images.